Let's look at the solution for the part three of our one cycle quiz,
which is about, if this is the state at the beginning of the cycle then
during this cycle, which if in instruction will this batch into the ALU here.
And, this instruction we already saw in part two.
Is going to free its reservation station and it's already executing, so
it will definitely not dispatch again. This instruction here,
will capture its last remaining operand during this cycle, so
it becomes eligible for dispatch after that.
We said that in the same cycle capture and then dispatch is allowed, so
this instruction here is a candidate for dispatching.
We're also going to issue this instruction here, into our reservation station.
But because the issue and the dispatch is not allowed in the same cycle,
that means that this instruction, even if its operands were ready,
would not be eligible for dispatch now. So the only instruction eligible for
dispatch is this one, which means that, that's the one that gets to dispatch.
If more than one instruction were eligible for dispatch, then we would have to
pick, which one dispatch is because we only have one execution unit. And
in order to do that, we would actually need to be told what are the rules for
picking among instructions.
Fortunately, we didn't need that because only one is eligible for dispatch.